w ministerstwie sprawiedliwości udało się coś
co było tak naprawdę największą hańbą ostatnich lat
odblokowaliśmy 600 miliardów złotych
zakończyliśmy tą głupią wojnę z unią europejską
pokazaliśmy plan naprawy praworządności
jesteśmy w nieustannym dialogu
w nieustannej dyskusji z komisją europejską
efektem tej dyskusji
jest między innymi entuzjastyczne przyjęcie 20. lutego
na radzie do spraw ogólnych
polskiego planu naprawy praworządności
21. maja również będziemy mieli kolejną dyskusję
na temat naprawy praworządności w polsce
i istnieje szansa
że procedura z artykułu 7.
która wisi nad polską
ta dyskusja zostanie rozpoczęta nad zdjęciem tej
procedury ale szanowni państwo
lewica w rządzie to także troska o prawa człowieka
lewica w rządzie to także
troska o poziom
debaty publicznej i walka z nienawiścią
w najbliższych tygodniach na radę ministrów płynie
projekt nowelizacji kodeksu karnego
który będzie zwalczał efektywnie
mowa nienawiści wobec mniejszości
mowa nienawiści wobec kobiet
mowa nienawiści wobec tych
którzy są dzisiaj w grupach mniejszościowych
koniec z nienawiścią
koniec z pogardzaniem 2. człowiekiem
koniec z poniewieraniem inną osobą tylko dlatego
że nie zgadzamy się z jej poglądami
lewica w rządzie to dobre relacje z unią europejską
ale lewica w rządzie
to także
ochrona praw człowieka i wolności obywatelskich